ok here we go onyx game white against
player called fold song from Turkey fold
some like the prison in the United
States may be best known because of the
the classic Johnny Cash album life at
folsom prison ok let's go um for Slovaks
change it's not the most exciting
opening in the world but I have very
good results and experience with it I
don't think I ever lost a game in a long
game with both colors actually yeah ok
the play done and I to you for this is
some fighting fighting option here what
can one swipes movie III I think Roxy
one is some problematic yeah III it's a
very high rated 2500 let's check quickly
if this is a provisional or something no
always got quite some games and yeah
it's like a strong player okay I think
and the only 95 Sam is one idea here if
I'm not mistaken so really some time
since I had a look at at the other side
lines a surprising choice i think i'm
sure what somewhat strange if you ask me
okay
okay maybe Bishop d7 yeah maybe the idea
is to have the bishop on this diagonal
if I place he fought at some point so
maybe an idea yeah still see four looks
like a very logical choice strategically
okay but what else can i play can play
out twin b3 of course then maybe queen a
fire from cabot I need to I need to
speed up so I'm fairly interesting now
positioned strategically would like to
have more time but yeah what can you do
rook c8 is coming quickly maybe queen
bee form I'd look somewhat stupid the
smooth but rook c8 is a problem okay
this is not brilliant maybe
yeah this was was bad play by me just
bad plane yet before was hanging
you have the issue is that is some just
quicker on the C file just rook c8
coming up quickly but maybe maybe this
isn't so bad actually for instance okay
if I if is also hanging so we need to
pay attention to this if it takes now do
have something else here too maybe maybe
some more dynamic idea okay come let's
let's take it cannot spend all day here
um yeah one idea is for instance of him
if he goes rook c8 okay and sister this
moment has already passed now can it to
go down yeah okay if I'm
cap Brooks is free I could play King
Ditu and then bishop age 6 f for what
this is terribly terribly ugly looking
but I came I cannot cook c3 is also also
not nice to to look at yeah of course
it's got so got g5 coming up but Sir
it's not exactly I'm difficult to see
all these hooves Jack
time warning
okay I don't have a little just simple
at that she takes her friday three it
sound wasn't so wasn't something i could
do again this yeah well this was just a
crap game very stupid play you really
shouldn't shouldn't lose like this in
this opening with white
maybe a maybe queen bees not sure but
what was the issue here queen bee three
Queenie five groups yet coming up yeah
yeah I could also resign ff2 for
instance just win so everything winds
take only three wins yeah okay why
reason yeah this was really crap game
really yeah yeah the smooth this is
somewhat irritating that it looks so
well no no bad frankly speaking but it's
somewhat irritating yeah maybe just just
Bishop d3 and cover this with Roxy one
if you just want to play Bishop b3 Roxy
a look see one now why not why not yeah
Queen be free I had a green before I had
a bad feeling about this and it was bad
well well then why did I play this
yeah this was off legend I just need to
play some normal developing move we
should be 3e to something I got some
time in this position I'm just better
with c4 coming he's got the week squares
everywhere he's 65 f 7 and so on yep
terrible game